[MUSIC PLAYING]
SHASHANK JOSHI: My
name is Shashank Joshi.
I'm a specialist leader in
cloud engineering practice
of Deloitte Consulting.
STEPHEN ELLIOTT: And
I'm Stephen Elliott.
I'm a product manager
on Cloud Billing.
SHASHANK JOSHI: All right,
so here is the quick agenda.
We'll start off with
the introduction--
what is cloud cost management,
why it is important.
And then we'll look at a
real-life enterprise example
where we helped build their
cloud cost management solution.
Then Stephen will talk about
what tools and services Google
Cloud provides for
cost management.
Then we'll see a couple of demos
to walk you through what you'll
hear in the session today.
And we'll wrap up with
Q&A. And just a reminder,
you can go to your Dory
app, ask a question,
or vote on a question
that you like.
All right, so let's get started.
What is cloud cost management?
Fundamentally, it's about
controlling-- or monitoring,
controlling, allocating,
and optimizing your cost.
So cloud promises accelerated
innovation and reduced cost.
But in reality,
that cost savings
are not always realized.
And another big
impact, a big change
from your traditional
OpEx model is,
in a traditional
environment, you
have your budgeting cycle done
once a year, or once a quarter,
right?
But in an OpEx
environment, you have
to do it on an ongoing basis.
So you need a solution
that can do that for you.
So just look at why
it is important,
the cloud cost management.
And you decided to
attend this session.
That means you understand
why it's important.
But still, let's go through
some of the analyst research
on this one.
So when asked about, what
is your greatest barrier
for cloud adoption,
the second greatest
barrier was cited as the
cloud cost management,
just only after cloud--
the data security, which can
be-- which is the number one
greatest barrier.
And within cloud cost
management, when asked,
what is your top pain--
so 61% of people said that the
predictability of your cloud
cost is the greatest
pain point for them.
And what happens if you don't
have a effective cloud cost
management solution?
So 69% would overspend up to
25% of their cloud budget.
So this is a significant number.
And if you don't have a plan
for cloud cost management,
you would overspend more
than 70% of your budget.
So these are really big numbers.
So it's still important to
have a cost management plan
and have a cost management
solution in place.
So now that we know why cloud
cost management is important,
you would want to start-- what
your solution has to answer.
So what are the questions you'd
want to answer using your cloud
cost management solution.
So the first important
fundamental question
is, how much does your app cost?
And depending on at what
level you are looking at,
it can be one app,
a bunch of apps,
or all of apps in
your organization.
So you would want
to know how much it
takes for you to deliver
value to your business
through your apps.
Second, for number two question,
is, what are your cost trends?
You can be in a
seasonal variation
industry or a regular industry.
But you should know,
what area your trends,
overall and also
for individual apps.
And finally, what are
your cost drivers?
So what is driving your cost?
What are your top
five spend areas.
How would you drill
down into that?
So that's another
important question.
Even though these are
fundamental questions--
and Google Cloud provides a
lot of solutions out of the box
that can answer these questions
for you in a matter of minutes,
that Stephen will
showcase later on--
but these are not
all the questions
that you need to answer.
These are the
fundamental questions,
but based on your
organization, you
may have much more--
many more questions.
So let's look at
one example where
we help build a billing data
analysis solution for a Fortune
500 retailer.
So just give a quick
background on this customer--
so a couple of years ago, they
started on a really big cloud
transmission journey using GCP.
We helped build a
business case for them.
And it was a very
exhaustive business case
in terms of what
initiatives, milestones,
going down all the way
to the applications.
And very early on
in the journey,
we realized the importance of
cloud cost management solution.
And as we were getting ready,
building the foundation,
getting ready for the
bigger transformation,
we also started building
the solution required
for cloud billing data
analysis and reporting.
So as part of the cloud
cost management team,
we were responsible for
oversight analysis reporting
for all aspects of
cloud cost management.
So we needed a system which
can meet all these challenges.
So the first set of challenges
were organizational challenges.
And I'm sure all bigger
organizations would really
face this.
So every organization will
have some kind of a structure.
For example, they'll have lines
of businesses, vice presidents,
departments, applications,
and stuff like that.
So how will you overlay all of
this data, your organization
structure, onto
your GCP billing?
Because you may have to
help showcase all of that
back using that structure.
And second option
was, how will you
combine multiple data sources?
So GCP Billing is
not the only source
of cost in your overall system.
So there are so
many other systems
like licensing, other
third-party tools, other colo
and other cloud
providers as well.
So how will you combine all
those multiple data sources?
So your solution has
to be robust enough
to combine all of these
sources and derive
meaningful insights from that.
And finally, in terms
of organization,
there are different
levels of stakeholders.
So how will you break down the
reporting or analysis based
on different stakeholders?
And how will you
control access, right?
You wouldn't want application--
line of business 1
to look at line of
business 2 data like that.
And in terms of data challenges,
working with billing export
schema is really important.
So sooner your team is very
familiar with the billing
export schema and
overall BigQuery,
it's really important.
And how would you distribute
shared services, right?
So there can be shared services
like networking, monitoring.
So how will you
distribute that cost?
And some of the
credits that come,
they come at the
organization level.
How will you distribute
those credits back
to the respective folks?
And finally, every
large organization
would have some kind of a data
analysis reporting solution
in terms of cost
already existing.
So whether you will choose to
extend that solution for GCP,
or you will want to build
a brand new one-- so that's
another question
you need to answer.
So with these
challenges in mind,
this is how we
came up with-- this
is a overview of the
architecture that we build.
So if you see, on
the left-hand side,
there are a bunch
of data sources.
Of course, GCP Billing export,
that was a major data source.
And as a best practice,
we have to enable--
you should enable GCP
export on day one.
And then there are
other GCP data.
For example, we actually had
a lot of other requirements
in terms of getting
more data from GCP--
for example, how
many instances are
running in our environment--
so any other
platform-related data.
So we had custom scripts
to capture all of that data
and use--
dump into BigQuery.
And then organizational
data, right-- all
of your org structure,
your VPs, your departments,
your budgets, all of that
organizational data has
to be brought in as well
for meaningful insights.
And we'll see that
in the demo later on.
You can have
third-party tools data.
And you can have other clouds,
or colo-provided data as well.
You would want one
single solution
to do-- to visualize
all of that,
right, instead of going to
multiple different solutions.
For storage and analysis,
we used BigQuery.
Initially, we started off
with a on-prem solution,
but later on,
realized, related to--
challenges related to
cost and functionality--
we decided to get everything
into Google Cloud--
so using BigQuery as our
storage and analysis solution.
And we'll see some
of the example
in our demo, how we
use that actually.
And we had a bunch of
automation and scheduling.
Because all of the org
data that you see here,
all the platform data that
is coming, all of that data
was automated.
So there were scripts running
all the time, scheduled.
And there were third-party--
or the organizational data
coming into CSV files.
And whenever there was
a change in the file,
the automation pipeline
would update the table.
And finally, we used
a bunch of BigQuery
views to join all of these
different data sources.
And for visualization,
we have used Tableau,
because that was
the tool of choice.
So before I go to
the next one, I just
want to highlight a couple of
key highlights of the solution.
So far cost organizations,
we used labels.
So we decided a labeling
strategy very early on.
And as a best practice, you
should spend time on deciding
the labeling strategy,
and not just for today's--
well near future, maybe
slightly longer than that.
Because it's really
hard to change once
you decide on a
labeling strategy.
That was one important part.
And because of that
labeling strategy,
we were able to drill
down not just by the VP,
but going down to
the department,
going down to the application,
going down to the environment.
So there was visibility going
across, all the way down.
Second interesting part.
We did was we used billing
export data merged with so
many other data sources.
And we'll see how that is
useful later on in the demo.
So don't be afraid to
really merge different data
sources with your billing
to get more insights.
And finally, we create a lot
of custom fields as well.
And we'll see one
example of that.
If you have seen your BigQuery
export, for every service,
you have multiple SKUs.
And for computing, for example,
there are thousands of SKUs.
So if you wanted to jump
from service to SKU,
that's a much bigger jump.
So we came up with a field
called SKU categories.
So we wanted to categorize some
of the SKUs into something more
higher-level and
more meaningful.
' Because not everybody would
want to go to the actual SKUs
later on.
And we'll see how that
helps later on as well.
And in terms of impact--
so the major impact was the
visibility from the get-go.
So we could track the spend on
a overall business case level.
And the leadership could
see, now, how they are doing
and make adjustments.
So this was a great tool
to the overall leadership,
to look at it and see how well
we are performing vis-a-vis
the business case.
And not just that--
because the reports were
available all the way down to
the app owners and developers,
it really helped make that
mindset change from CapEx
to OpEx.
As the granular-level
data was available,
they could see impact
of their actions.
If they design an
application in a certain way,
they could see a positive or
negative impact on the cost
immediately in near real terms.
So that really helped create
the CapEx to OpEx mindset.
And in terms of analysis,
because everybody
could see what their budget is
and how their spend is going
on a daily, monthly,
weekly basis,
it created a culture
of accountability
across the organization.
And as everybody could see, what
are their top areas of spend,
they could manage what are
their top areas of spend,
do something about it,
and kind of control that.
And overall, it helped
improve the forecasting
and predictability.
Because everybody was able to
see how much their application
cost yesterday, today,
and based on the load
variations, what it
will cost tomorrow.
And finally, in
terms of insights,
it helped identify a lot of
optimization opportunities.
And couple of
examples I can give--
when we realized the compute
cost was much higher,
we'd dig deeper into that.
We saw, in one instance, the
licensing cost was much higher.
So we decided to look
at, why is it higher.
So is it-- is there some way
that we can address that?
Maybe using BYOL, right,
we can reduce the cost.
Other examples
were we identified
a lot of storage-related
costs in compute.
And then that's where the
custom scripts came in handy.
Because we wrote
custom scripts that
could go through
all of your projects
and find out orphan disks,
that disks which are not
attached to any instance.
So you're paying for storage
for those instances--
those disks-- and
not using them.
So that is-- that was
another opportunity
to delete, or take a snapshot,
or do something about that.
And finally, other opportunities
in terms of making this
as part of your culture--
the cost optimization is
becoming part of your culture.
And to do that, we
had regular governance
meetings with our
lines of businesses
on trends and recommendations.
So rather than making
it once a quarter
or a long-term activity, we
made it a habit, our governance,
to do it, like, biweekly basis.
And one of the
interesting anecdote
I remember from one
of such meetings
was when we were helping
out predicting one--
how to predict the cost
for one of the LoBs.
We realized, for a peak--
because it's a retail
customer, there
were peaks and troughs
for their usage.
And we were trying to
estimate how much it will
cost when it goes on a peak.
So obviously, we had a unit
cost on a traditional basis.
But during a peak, your overall
on-demand usage goes up, right?
So you have certain
commitments for a lower cost,
but you cannot make commitments
for a short period of peak.
So during the peak, your
on-demand instance usage
goes up.
And that actually
pushes your unit price
for compute up higher as well.
So when predicting for
a peak, you not just
have to predict for
the increased capacity,
you have to predict--
use the increased
unit cost as well.
Keep in mind that as well.
So that insight was really
useful for some of the LoBs
to make accurate
predictions about how
the peak would look like.
And finally, before closing
out about this use case,
what are some of the key
takeaways that you can take
back to your billing systems?
So the first one
is billing analysis
and reporting is not one and
done kind of solution, right?
And we actually
developed this solution
in a very agile,
iterative fashion.
So don't try to collect
all your requirements
for all your dashboards
very early in the cycle.
You should start
building reports
and start improving on
that on a biweekly basis.
So if you do it in
an iterative fashion,
that's the best way to do it.
The second one is, decide your
data pipeline and reporting
tack early on.
We had to make corrections,
adjustment in the midway.
But always, you should
do some due diligence
to decide your data
pipeline stack early on.
And identifying
optimization opportunities
should not be a
rarely occurring thing
it should be happening
much more regularly.
That way, you can
control your cost.
So with that, I'll
hand it over to Stephen
to talk about the cloud cost
management tools on GCP.
STEPHEN ELLIOTT: All
right, thank you, Shashank.
This is actually kind of
funny, because I never
thought I would get to present
Billing in an IMAX theater.
So it's an exciting
day, because I
get to take check that
off my thrilling bucket
list of life goals.
So we talked to lots of
customers, big and small.
And there's several key
themes-- and Shashank kind of
alluded to these--
that we want to address
with our cost management tools.
And these are what's on
the screen right now.
So visibility--
the basic ability
to view your costs in a way
that's meaningful to you.
Accountability-- so once
you know the cost of some
meaningful, logical
grouping-- say,
the fully-loaded cost of the
application I just shipped last
week--
now, who do I hold
accountable for the cost
of that application?
Who do I reward for having
delivered it efficiently?
And who do I have
a meeting with who
did not deliver it efficiently?
But more seriously, what
is the corrective action
if you see costs
starting to run away?
And then control--
now this is a big one,
because there's both the
proactive, explicit control,
and the tools that you
use to control costs,
and then there's just
the sense of control.
And that one's hard
to put a finger on.
But often, a bunch
of different tools
can give you the sense and the
feeling of being in control.
That's often just as important
for you and your leadership.
You know, if you're
a CIO, or a VP,
or you're an
engineering manager,
it's that sense of
control that lets
you be confident that you're
doing the right thing.
And then intelligence-- so
you expect to get insights
about your costs, suggestions
about where you can optimize
what you're spending, and
get those from the platform,
and get that easily
from the data.
So those are the four
priorities we have on Billing.
And I'm going to talk
through the tools,
and then show you the tools,
and then demo the tools.
So there'll be three
different ways depending
what kind of learner you are.
So we have built-in reports that
come straight out of the box.
They're ready to slice and
dice in the Billing console.
If you want to get access
to the detailed data,
we export all the detailed
data, like Shashank mentioned,
to BigQuery, which is
a really powerful tool
to get really fast query results
on large amounts of data.
So you won't be
limited by BigQuery
if you want to join it
against rich operational data.
We have recommendations.
So various products have
different recommendations,
for example.
Compute Engine has VM
rightsizing recommendations
to show you where you
might want to have a larger
instance, or a smaller
instance, depending
on how you're actually using the
cores and memory in your VMs.
And then customizable
dashboards--
so this would be, in the
case of a Google product,
Data Studio plugged
into BigQuery.
Or if you have your own
solution-- you know,
you're using Tableau, or Looker,
or some other solution-- plug
that into BigQuery as well.
On the accountability and
control side of the house,
again, this is all
about giving you
the tools you need to feel
like you are in control,
and can see costs, and
don't get surprised by costs
as your teams are iterating and
kind of operating autonomously.
So one is just billing
access control,
being able to set the rights to
view costs for the right users.
By default, billing account
administrators and project
owners and users get to see the
costs of what they're doing.
Then we have budget alerts
and automated actions.
So you can set
notification thresholds
on your spending in a project
or in a billing account
so that you receive an email if
spending goes over a threshold.
Or you get a
Pub/Sub message sent
to some programmatic
function that responds to it
and takes corrective action.
And then there's the
resource hierarchy.
So this is just how
you want to organize
your resources, your
usage into projects,
have multiple projects
under a folder,
have all of that
under your domain,
and then set standard
policies at the right level
of the hierarchy.
And then finally
here, there's quota.
And so one way to
think about quota
is the proactive control of
usage, setting, in advance,
what someone's allowed to use.
And then budgets and
alerts, that's notification.
So that's a lagging indicator to
respond to things after they've
exceeded a certain threshold.
So this graph makes me laugh,
just because I stubbornly
oversimplify it despite
the most vigorous feedback
from my engineers.
So on the left, there's usage
metering from GCP products.
So if you're using
Compute Engine or Storage,
it's emitting usage to what
I've called, here, the pricing
engine, which doesn't exist.
This is a chimera.
It's not a real thing.
But it's a really complex
system that takes the usage,
figures out the right
pricing, and credits,
and discounts to apply
to it, and packages that
to send to downstream systems.
So one is important to us.
That's payments.
That's how we make money.
But for this talk, the yellow
items and the red items
are what are important.
So we send the
cost and the usage
downstream to all the
cost management tools--
billing reports,
export, and dashboards,
and budgets and alerts.
So if you run into Jonathan
Thorndycraft or anyone else,
and you talk to them, just
don't mention the word "pricing
engine."
Talk about something else.
But this is basically
what it does.
There's a great talk about
resource management-- actually,
later today, I'll give
you the talk number--
by Greg and Max, teammates.
But at a high level, the items
that you should think about
are, how do you set policies
and users in your domain
and organization?
And then, how do you
pay for your projects
with a billing account?
Usually, most customers
have one billing account,
so this shouldn't
require too much thought.
The payment profile-- just
something to be aware of
and make sure you have the
right users set on those,
so they receive the
invoices and they're
able to pay for the invoice.
And then projects,
folders, and labels,
which Shashank referred
to and I mentioned,
which are the ways to
organize their resources
and be able to identify
costs of the same group--
So this is the
part where I'm just
going to show you what all these
things are before I demo them.
So reports look like this.
They work out of the box.
You don't have to
set anything up.
And anytime you
log in, you can see
a report that lets you
slice and dice the costs
for easy visibility.
And then billing export--
if you go to BigQuery
and you have billing
export enabled,
you can just look at the table
where all the costs are going
and either run the
queries in line
here, run the query via a
command line, or via an API,
or plug it into Data
Studio or Tableau,
and then maybe have an
experience where you don't even
need to write the query.
For example, in Data
Studio, you can just
do a what you see is what
you get configuration
of the charts that pulls
directly from billing export
and then gives you
something like this.
And we actually
have a template--
and Shashank will
show that in a demo--
where you can just
copy the template,
plug in your export
table, and then get
it to start populating real
data from your own account.
And budgets and alerts, this is
per billing account or project.
And then you can easily set
multiple alert thresholds
based on actual spending
level or a forecasted spending
amount.
And that's a new release.
We came out with that
just a couple weeks ago.
So that's a nice one
that I'll talk about.
And then just the mental model
for how programmatic budget
alerts and programmatic
consumption of those alerts
work--
you can think of--
the manual method
is we send an email to the
billing administrator and say,
your spending is
approaching your threshold.
You might want to do something
about it, or just a heads-up.
Programmatically, if we sent
the same message to a Pub/Sub
topic, you could have
something like a Cloud Function
in just the Pub/Sub
topic message anytime
it arrives, and then
decide what to do with it.
So for example, one solution
would be to just send a Slack
message to a Slack group
and say, hey, just FYI,
the budget's-- the
spending is trending up.
Or if it's a sandbox
project and you're
completely comfortable
blowing it away,
you could have a more
draconian programmatic response
this says, OK, you
spent more than $500.
That was your test account.
Your test account's
been shut down.
And this is just kind of a
small pitch to Cloud Function.
But when I say
it's easy to write
the programmatic consumption
of the Pub/Sub message,
Cloud Functions are
really short snippets
of code in common languages.
So here we have a
very short function
that does a quick budget
check and then does--
kind of pushes
the big red button
and says disable billing,
because we exceeded the budget.
So for budgets and quota,
again, keep in mind,
budgets are your
lagging indicator.
It's when the spending
has happened, which means
the usage happened before that.
And quota is your
proactive control.
And the quota policies can be
set for different products.
You can decide
whether or not a user
should be able to
run a lot of BigQuery
or run a lot of instances.
And on budgets, that
is kind of a catch-all.
So if the project
spends a certain level,
that captures all the
products in that project.
If a billing account
spends a certain level,
that just captures all of
the spending and activity
in the billing account.
So quotas are also more
targeted to the actual products
being used.
So another important
aspect to cost management--
and many of you may
be familiar with this.
But if you get
into a good rhythm
of building the dashboards,
as Shashank mentioned,
and having teams
accountable for their costs,
and regularly checking
these, it actually
does something
interesting, and it
makes the culture more
operationally in tune
with what's going on.
We've had customers like,
here, Vendasta, Dale Birch,
say that once they've put
up their cost management
dashboards, they've identified
things they probably wouldn't
have identified otherwise.
So they have a great talk
where they're talking
about runaway storage spending.
So usually, storage spending
that runs away slowly
is something that's
kind of hard to catch.
And then you might
notice it over months.
But you would have to actually
look at the long-term trend
and have someone
proactively look at that.
But if you just have a
dashboard that says year
to date spending, and you
see a trend that's going up,
it's hard to miss,
just because humans
are so great at identifying
the visual trend.
And usually, cost is a
great proxy for operations.
So if there's a
deviation in cost,
or there's a trend in cost
that doesn't look right,
but just looks like it deviated
from the past pattern, usually
that correlates to something
interesting or wrong
in operations.
And it's just a
really nice proxy
that everyone
understands, whether it's
the VP or the engineer,
that something has started
to change from the status quo.
Great, so for the demo, while
Shashank sets that up, what
we're going to do is we're going
to do an end to end and show
you how we recommend
using the different tools,
starting from the simplest
use case to the more
involved customer use
case that Shashank
was talking about
with his engagement
with the retail customer.
So right now we're
in the Cloud console.
This is the home
page for a project.
And there's two ways to
get to your cost data.
The first one is just
the Billing card.
And here, the project
spent $235 so far--
it's all the way over there--
$235 so far this month.
And I can either go to
Billing reports here--
But before I do
that, I just want
to show you that you can also go
to the Billing page in console
by just coming to
the Billing menu
and then going to
Reports down here.
But for now, I'm going
to go to it via the card.
So I'll see-- first
question I might
ask is, where's that
$235 coming from?
Is it under control?
Does it look like it's a
reasonable amount of spend.
So if I click on View
detailed charges--
View detailed charges--
great, OK, so now I'm here.
This is amazing.
I'm going to zoom out.
This is the most high-powered
projector, and yet somehow--
all right.
So once you're in reports,
what we were mentioning
is you get an at-a-glance
view of where you're spending
has come from and
where it's going.
Is this a right size, or
should I zoom in a bit more?
It's fine?
OK.
So you immediately get a sense
of what your overall spending
is on the left, to date-- $235.
We actually spun
this up for the demo.
So that's a big increase
over the previous 10 days.
And then we have a
projection of what
we think we're going to spend
by the end of the month-- so
$250 by the end of the month.
Now that's curious.
You would think that if we
spent $235 in the first 10 days
of the month, the projection
should be something more
like $600, $700 by
the end of the month.
But the way we're
doing the projection
is we're looking at--
I'll just do a
custom date range.
We're looking at the
historical spend trend here.
So if I went back
to January and said,
what's the trend in spending,
well, usually, here usually
means, the last time
we used this project,
we did a big burst
and then shut it down.
And so that's why the
projection thinks that we're not
going to exceed $250.
So that's just this project.
And what I can see
is that the spending
is coming from some SKUs.
So N1 predefined instance core,
that's a Compute Engine core
part of the VM.
And then it must be running
Windows, because there's
a Windows Server license
on it, Data Center Edition,
and then some RAM
for those instances.
But that might be too
granular, so let's see-- group
by product.
And it's all Compute Engine.
And there's some Stackdriver
logging at zero cost.
So the next thing
I might want to do
is just say, well, I'm the
billing account administrator.
Let's look at-- so
if I wanted to see
all of the spending in
the billing account,
I could just select
all projects.
So right now, it shows me just
one of the 18 in this billing
account, because I'd come to
it from the project home page.
So show me everything.
And let me know how my entire
team is doing spending-wise.
So now that forecast has
changed, because the spending
across the billing account,
across all the projects
is different.
So I might group by
project, just to see,
what are the
high-spending projects.
And so far, the highest-spending
project this month
is Phills Amazing Application.
And the one we had come from
was the Phill Good App--
Dev.
And again, where's this
trend line coming from?
Do a custom range, maybe
take it back to January.
So you can see, as we're
ramping up for Next
we've been doing some more
test-- some more demo testing,
spinning up some VMs.
So Shashank can show you the
demo later in this session.
And then the forecast is
actually saying, well,
typically, on this
day the month,
you've been spinning this much.
And you've been increasing
month over month.
So we think you'll have kind
of a big spike in spend around
here, and then
it'll go down again.
So the nice thing about
the quick, slice and dice
ability of reports
is, now you can
start to answer some real
questions really quickly,
even operational ones.
So one thing I might
want to know is--
I see that the Phill Good App--
Dev suddenly started
having usage.
It didn't have usage
before mid-March.
So I might want to
focus just on that one
and say, well, where's
that spending coming from?
And why is it getting started?
So if I focus on that,
it looks like there
was a bunch of
spending that happened
around March 12, March 13.
And again, I can drill back in.
We saw what that was, that
it was a Compute Engine.
And then when we
looked at it even more,
we saw that it was an N1
predefined instance core.
So once we've identified
something interesting, then--
this only takes a
matter of minutes--
you can go to Stackdriver and
just see, in the logs, well,
who's responsible?
What's responsible
for the spending?
We know, generally
speaking, it's
a predefined instance core.
So if we were to
go to Stackdriver--
does this go here?
Stackdriver logging-- I'm
still in the same project--
so Phill Good App--
Dev.
And I'm interested in
these VMs instances,
who's running
these VM instances,
where they come from.
Let's look at the activity logs.
So we got compute activity log.
And then here, we had a
date range of interest
So it was March--
let's say March 13
can be the start date,
and then maybe look at
the whole day there.
Set end date.
And so now I'm
looking at the logs.
And I can immediately start to
see some instance insertions.
So here, it looks like we've
been having some activity.
And some of the
activity-- so here,
there are some config
changes by Shashank.
And if I looked further, I'd
see some instances getting
stopped by Shashank, and
then some instances getting
started, right?
So now I've got a sense
of the accountability.
It's my partner, Shashank.
That's great.
It could be me, because
I am logged in as him.
But I'm going to
pretend that it's him.
So the next thing I want to do
is just set a budget on that.
So actually, I'll show
you how to get there.
So I'd say, well, you know,
I trust him to an extent.
But I don't-- I wouldn't
trust him with my entire demo.
So go to Billing, and
then go to Budgets.
And say, well, let's
set some notifications
on the billing account.
So the project was
Phill Good App--
Dev.
Go to the linked billing
account for that.
And then set a budget for it.
So now I'm going
to create a budget.
And this is pretty fast.
So budget-- don't let
Shashank spend more--
budget.
And let's see, Billing reports
demo, that's the project.
And you know, the budget amount
might be something like $1,000.
So I don't ask for
more than $1,000.
I'm comfortable with $1,000
for the demo, for the month,
but not that much more.
And then now, the
auto-suggested thresholds
are, notify me at
50%, 90%, 100%.
Another interesting thing that
we launched is you could say,
I would also like to be
notified when I am projected--
oops, it has to be unique.
So I'm just going to delete
that and use the last one-- when
I'm projected or forecasted
to exceed the budget.
And so you don't have to wait
until you exceed a threshold.
Just say, when we
forecast that you're
going to exceed the
budget, even if it's only
the 10th of the month or
the 15th of the month,
we should alert on that.
And then finally, you could
either send that via email
or connect it to a Pub/Sub
topic if you want to respond
to it programmatically.
And because you can
have multiple budgets,
you could set one this
just sends an email,
and then set an
identical one then sets--
that sends a Pub/Sub--
Pub/Sub alert.
So I think the topic
is in this project.
You just have to
select a Pub/Sub
topic to send the message to.
So alert email-- save that.
And then you have a
budget that helps me stay
in control of my demo spending.
And then, again,
the Cloud Function
itself could be very simple.
So if you're going
into Cloud spending,
if you go into Cloud Functions--
oops, I'll just cheat
and go over to the tabs--
you'll get a list of all the
functions in your project.
And this one is actually
one that's very simple.
It responds to any messages
sent to the Pub/Sub
topic, alert email.
And in this case, it's a
function that just forwards it.
It's not truly an email.
It just forwards it to Slack.
And that-- if you're using a
standard language like Node.js,
just include the Slack library,
and then post a message to it.
So this is a fake token.
But post a message
to the Slack channel.
And they'll just
post the contents
of your Pub/Sub message.
And that is your function.
You don't have to
do anything else.
And when you hit
Deploy, that function
will start responding
to the budget alert.
So it's a really powerful tool.
And you can learn more
about it in a deep dive talk
that my colleague Phill
Coletti is going to give.
So now that I've
gone through how
I control Shashank's
spending, I'll
let him talk through
billing export and data
through your dashboards.
SHASHANK JOSHI: Sure,
thanks, Stephen.
I really hope you didn't catch
my pet project, but you did.
So the tools are pretty good.
So I'm going to talk
about, how will you
overlay some of the
org data that I spoke
about in the enterprise
example with your billing data
and how we can use that.
So just to set an
example, let's say
you have multiple LoBs in
your environment, three Lines
of Businesses, multiple VPs.
If you see these names familiar,
these are the Docker container
name generator.
So these are the VPs.
And each of the VPs would
have one or more applications.
And each applications
would have environments.
And each environment would
be in a specific project.
And to overlay this structure
with your billing usage,
you have to have a
labeling strategy.
So I'm using labels
such as environment--
so whether it's a
dev, test, prod--
what lob it is--
lob1, lob2, lob3--
what app it is--
whether it's
phill-good, all-is-well.
And you get the idea.
We are using some
interesting names here.
So this is good.
But how will you really
implement that into BigQuery,
where you can
create, for example--
billing export is
where your export is.
And you can create another
data set for the org data.
So we have a table
for LoB to VP mapping.
Let me show you that.
So it can be your LoB
mapping back to your VP name.
And we'll see, how will you join
that with your billing export?
And let's go to the
next level of details.
So you may have some budgets
for your individual VPs.
So you can create another
table that maps your VP
with your month and budget.
And all of these details
can be stored in a CSV file.
And you can create a
automation pipeline.
So whenever there is a-- and you
can check these CSV files back
into your source
code repository.
And whenever there is a change--
let's say a new VP
joins, or a VP leaves,
or a budget changes
on a month on month--
you update the CSV file.
And that automatically
updates your BigQuery table.
So that's about your org data to
overlay with your billing data.
Now let's look at some
of the other data.
I mentioned about SKU categories
as a custom field that we used.
So that's where we
created a table that
gets your service, all
your SKUs, and inserts
a category cards SKU category
just for simplicity there.
And let me show you
how effective is that.
So here I am using--
for example, for Compute Engine,
just if you see the licensing
itself-- so as I
mentioned, there are, like,
thousands of services--
SKUs.
And within Compute--
just for licensing,
there are hundreds of SKUs.
So if you see, there
are-- in this case,
there are 16 different SKUs in
my usage itself for licensing.
And for reporting,
I may just want
to see-- or clip all of them
together as licensing, right?
So that's what I'm doing here.
And then let's look at--
the other important
thing I mentioned
was about the platform data.
So in this case, I actually
created a Python script
using Google APIs.
What it does is it goes
through all of your products,
gets all of your instance
data, and dumps it
into a BigQuery table.
And you can schedule
this script to run
every two hours, or every day,
based on what you want to use.
And this is just one example.
The API is so
enormous and useful,
you can write as
many custom scripts.
So this particular
script gets the details
of the project it's running
in, what instance and name,
what region and zone
it's running in,
and how many cores and RAM
does the instance have.
And we'll see how
that data is used.
And because we are using
project labels to map
to line of business, now you
can map all of these instances
back to your VP.
So now we have
created the structure.
So there is a billing table.
And there are a bunch
of different tables
for your org data,
for your other data.
Now let's see how we
can join all of this
to make some
meaningful dashboards.
So for that, we create
a bunch of views.
Let's look at those views.
So the first view that you see
here is a billing daily view.
So here, what we are
joining here is--
I hope the text is visible.
So we are joining the
main building table
with the SKU categories
and with the LoB mapping.
So what you get
as a result is you
can map your billing
usage by your VP
and by the SKU category.
So you're merging these--
joining these--
the three tables.
The other view is the
billing monthly budget view.
So in this view, you're
joining your billing table
with your LoBs as well
as your monthly budget.
So that's how you are
joining these two tables.
And finally, the
instance data and VP--
so in this particular
view, you're
joining the instance data with
the VP table and the LoB table.
So this is just an
example to set it up,
how you can join
different tables together
with your billing export.
So you created the
tables, additional tables.
Of course, you had
a billing export.
Then you need to
create a bunch of views
on how to join these
different tables.
And then finally, you
create the dashboards.
And as Stephen mentioned,
it's really easy
to do Data Studio dashboards.
If you just search on GCP
Billing Data Studio sample
on Google, you'll see that.
You'll see Stephen's photo here.
I think it's a really
nice talk from last year--
so a must-see, must
see your YouTube video.
So what you do is you just
click on this one, this link.
And it takes you to a page here.
And there are details given on
how to-- how Data Studio works.
But more interestingly, there is
start working with your sample
billing report.
So you just click on this link.
That takes you to
a sample dashboard.
So that gives you, out of the
box, many dashboards, right?
Your analysis by projects,
analysis by resources, spending
trends, App Engine, BigQuery--
all of these reports
are available to you.
And it's so easy to use
in your environment.
You just click on Make a copy,
and give your data source,
your billing export here.
So in my case, it's
Billing_Export_Table.
I just click on Copy report.
And all those
dashboards you see,
those that are available for
my environment out of the box.
So this is how easier
it is to really do this.
So this is-- this can give
you out-of-the-box reports.
But how to make some of the
custom reports that we saw?
So many tables, so many views--
how do you consume that?
So let's go to the next cost
management custom reports--
and a shout out to David Wright,
who helped, creating some
of these reports and views.
So the first one-- because you
saw the first view that we had
was combining the VP and LoB
table with our billing export.
And because of that--
let me increase
the font size here.
So because of that, you could
see the spending by the VPs.
So you can see that Amazing
Aryabhata is spending
most of the money for you.
The other insight
that you see here
is there are some
unassigned costs as well.
So these are the projects
which you have not labeled.
And it's really important, as
organization, for you to see,
what are my costs that are not
labelled, not allocated, right?
So it's really important.
And it's clearly
visible from here.
Now let's look at-- we had
budgets for everybody, right?
So let's look at
how they are doing
vis-a-vis the budgets
that they have.
So this is the view where
we combine the budgets
table with the billing table.
So you can see, for example,
Relaxed Richie is our VP.
He's below our budget, so he
can continue to stay relax.
Let's look at somebody else.
So Mr. Trusting Torvalds is
actually exceeding his budget.
So we'll have to have
a discussion with him,
and why is that.
So you can see what they're
doing vis-a-vis daily budget
and monthly as well.
You see daily spend, monthly
spend, vis-a-vis their budgets.
Coming back to the
SKU categories,
because these are
categories, these
are much higher-level
abstractions.
So you see licensing fees here
as the second biggest cost
driver.
That gives you a
really good view
of where your cost is going.
So instance VCPU is
definitely number one,
but licensing is number two.
So you would want to drill down.
And as Stephen saw--
I mean, he caught me
with my pet project--
that is a bunch of Windows
machines, Windows licensing
that had licenses as well.
So you may want to look at
that as cost optimization.
And finally, let's look at
some of the custom GCP scripts.
So we had the custom GCP script
getting all the instance data,
and how that is useful combining
with your other org data.
So now you can see, by each
VP, how many different types
of instances they
are running, right?
So why it is useful,
you may be running
a lot of-- your developers
may be running a lot of custom
instances, right?
So that is an
optimization opportunity
where you would go to
the standard instance
and save some cost.
Instances per zone, this may
be important from availability
perspective if you're
oversubscribing
one zone or another.
For example, in this case,
Amazing Aryabhata is going to--
his team is prioritizing
one zone over others.
And these dashboards of cores
and RAM per zone, these details
are really useful
for you to make
informed decision on
how many commitments
you want to buy on each of the
zones-- or each of the regions.
And finally, whether--
instance status--
you can do it like,
running, terminated.
How many instances which
just shut down and just
left like that?
You would want to kill
those or delete those.
This is just example--
just a few examples.
But you can make as
many custom reports
and combine that together.
STEPHEN ELLIOTT: OK,
thanks, Shashank.
And can we switch
back to the slides?
All right, so just
to wrap up, we
mentioned some best practices.
These slides will be
available online later.
But these are worth reiterating,
which is, on day one,
you've seen the value of
having billing export enabled.
So you should enable that when
you have a billing account.
And that way, that
historical data is always
available to you.
And in my demo, I showed
you how reports are just
a very easy tool to
use to quickly find
a date range and a product
or SKU of interest,
and then use that as
your jumping-off point,
whether it's Stackdriver
or the detailed logs.
And that exploration,
if you know the tools,
can take a matter of
minutes to figure out
what's driving something.
Finally, it's really worth
putting in some effort
to think about how
you organize your work
and how you want to manage
your costs to build custom
dashboards off of that from
the detailed billing data
so that you can spread
those dashboards.
Data Studio lets you
share them easily.
So you can share those
dashboards with your company.
And then related to that is just
developing your cost management
strategy and thinking about how
you're organizing the resources
and the projects, how you
want to label cross-cutting
spend across different projects
and different resource types
so that you can easily see
fully-loaded application costs
or fully-loaded team costs.
And then finally, if you do all
this right, just really work
at building that culture of cost
ownership, making sure people
actually use the cost
dashboards and our iteratively
improving it, as Shashank
was mentioning earlier,
so that they both get the cost
accountability side of it,
but also the engineering
excellence that
can come out of being
really strong cost owners.
[MUSIC PLAYING]